wirtschaft will entlastungen bürger und
bürgerinnen wollen entlastungen im
grunde eigentlich alle aber wie soll das
fair und gerecht gehen und bezahlbare
vor allen dingen insbesondere für bürger
und bürgerinnen bei denen das geld
sowieso schon knapp ist darüber rede ich
jetzt mit der wirtschaftspolitischen
sprecherin der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion julia
klöckner schirm guten morgen
guten morgen brachen fangen wir erstmal
mit der wirtschaft an es gibt ja bisher
zwei entlastungspaket jetzt soll es ein
drittes geben sagen sie mir mal einen
punkt der für sie aus wirtschafts nicht
unbedingt drin stehen muss
genauso wie die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher also die bürger hat die
wirtschaft auch unglaublich zu kämpfen
mit den gestiegenen kosten und deshalb
ist es ganz wichtig was in
beiderseitiger interesse ist sowohl vom
arbeitgeber als auch vom arbeitnehmer
dass jetzt endlich die sogenannte kalte
progression ausgeglichen wird sie müssen
sich vorstellen der staat verdient
allein in diesem jahr zehn milliarden
euro dadurch dass er den bürgern diese
versteckte steuererhöhung nicht
ausgleich das heißt die kaufkraft selbst
massiv nach man bekommt für einen euro
viel weniger und das muss der staat
ausgleichen damit die lohn preis spirale
nicht nach oben geben der zweite punkt
ist es geht ja nicht nur darum dass die
großabnehmer von energie entlastet
werden so wie es herr beck vor hat
sondern auch die kleinen bäckereien die
mittelständler die dezentral bei uns im
ganzen land sind dass man ihnen auch
behilflich ist sie fordern also unter
anderem auch für unternehmen die auf
wettbewerbsfähige energiepreise
angewiesen sind wirksame maßnahmen aber
wie will man dann gleichzeitig bürger
und bürgerinnen erklären dass sie sparen
sollen und mehr zahlen aber der
industrie senkt man dann die strompreise
sie setzen voraus dass die industrie das
unternehmen nicht einsparen würden das
gegenteil ist ja nachweislich der fall
schauen sie mal jetzt zum beispiel die
gas umlage oder auch die gestiegenen
kosten die machen über 6000 euro pro
arbeitsplatz aus und das heißt dass die
industrie dass die unternehmen alles
mögliche tun gerade um genau diese
kosten zu senken das heißt
einsparpotenziale aufzuheben und es geht
am ende darum dass es auch
wirtschaftliche verwerfungen gibt es
geht um den standort deutschlands geht
um arbeitsplätze es geht um die menschen
die arbeitende mitte die einen
arbeitsplatz haben die denn auch
behalten wollen und deshalb ist das
unser aller interesse sie können nur das
verteilen was ja auch erwirtschaftet
worden ist und man kann keinen
zurücklassen nur dann wenn man auch eine
starke wirtschaft hat darum geht es
dieses
gesamtwirtschaftliche und
gesellschaftliche denken und bei der
ampel hat man den eindruck dass jede
partei oder fraktion immer irgendetwas
bekommt und dann fehlt der überblick
irgendwann in der ampel und das merken
wir ja jetzt zum beispiel auch mit
dieser sogenannten chaos umlage da liegt
ja keiner mehr durch selbst in der
bundesregierung lassen sie uns noch mal
auf die haushalte zu sprechen kommen
frau klöckner einige in der cdu fordern
wie die linke übrigens ein gas
basispreis also ein gaspreis decke
andere die mehrwertsteuersenkung dann
sagen wieder andere dass es sowieso
alles quatsch weil alle haushalte
profitieren davon wie würden sie
einkommensschwache haushalte rentner und
rentnerinnen studierende zielgenau und
schnell entlasten
wir dürfen erstens die bürger nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen es haben alle
jetzt gerade richtig mehr zu schultern
und zu tragen und es geht nicht um die
obersten reichen oder die untersten
einkommen nur alleine es gibt auch
menschen die die arbeitende mitte sind
die
eben diese erhöhung auch nicht einfach
wegstecken können und das heißt ganz
konkret das ist zb falsch war bei
entlastungs paketen rentner und
studierende einfach außen vor zu lassen
aber es genauso falsch die aus dem blick
zu lassen die gerade drüber liegen mit
ihrem einkommen deshalb keine transfers
bekommen aber selbst nicht wissen wie
sie das schultern sollen deshalb geht es
um ein gesamtkonzept was wir brauchen
noch einmal das thema kalte progression
das hatten wir in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode haben wir die immer
ausgeglichen diese steuererhöhungen sie
müssen sehen der staat verdient übrigens
mit einem gestiegenen prozentpunkt
inflation 10 milliarden euro bekommen
talent macht und das muss an die bürger
zurückgegeben werden zweiter punkt ist
die stromsteuer es ist ja nicht nur die
mehrwertsteuer sind wir haben auch eine
strom steuert der staat selbst ist der
preistreiber da könnten wir richtig
runter gehen von
2,05 cent pro kilowattstunde runter
europarechtlich auf 0,05 cent pro
kilowattstunde also steuern abgaben
runter die der staat selber noch teuer
macht bei den bürgern was wäre denn mit
der idee die die steuern zahlen über den
steuertarif also über die
einkommensteuer zu entlasten und andere
die keine steuern zahlen
transferleistungsempfänger etc bekommen
dann eine zusatzzahlung zum beispiel
heizkostenzuschuss weil man muss schon
auf die unteren und mittleren einkommen
schauen denn also die reichen brauchen
zeit unbedingt also menschen wie sie und
ich brauchen doch jetzt wirklich keine
entlastung
also wir müssen das ist ja mein punkt
genau sind dass wir nicht einzelne
gruppen gegeneinander ausspielen wir
wollen ja nicht dass wir soziale
spaltung in dieser gesellschaft bekommen
und deshalb brauchen wir etwas natürlich
für den wirtschaftsstandort deutschland
wir brauchen etwas für diejenigen die
zum beispiel keine einkommensteuer
zahlen aber die gestiegenen kosten haben
deshalb spielt auch das thema hartz 4
warenkorb eine ganz große rolle wir
müssen schauen im vergleich zum
vorherigen jahr sind lebensmittel um 15
prozent etwa teurer geworden und das
macht jede familie gerade die mit
kleinem einkommen und dann müssen wir
natürlich schauen dass diejenigen die
mehr tragen können auch mehr tragen so
ist das ja auch bei uns im steuerrecht
und deshalb noch einmal ist braucht ein
gesamtkonzept und nicht jede woche einen
neuen vorschlag der werde durch einen
nächsten korrigiert wird und da muss die
ampel sich zusammensetzen und nichts
zuerst belastungen beschließen und sich
dann uneinig seien über die entlastung
der belastung beschließen muss auch
wissen wie ihr entlang also das ist
entlastung braucht darüber sind sich
glaube ich alle einig über das wie eben
nicht darüber haben wir jetzt diskutiert
und beim nächsten mal sprechen doch
darüber wie das alles bezahlt werden
soll julia klöckner vielen dank für das
gespräch heute
danke